[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا في كل مكان اهلا بكم جميعا الى
حلقه جديده من برنامج من واشنطن
غزو روسيا لاوكرانيا تسبب لافريقيا في
متاعب اقتصاديه كبيره في مختلف المجالات
فمنذ اندلاع الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه شهد
العالم بما فيه افريقيا تعثرا في امدادات
القمح الاوكراني الى العديد من مناطق
العالم
وتواجه افريقيا بما فيها منطقه الشمال
الافريقي من موريتانيا حتى مصر مرورا طبعا
بالمغرب والجزائر وتونس وليبيا تواجه
ارتفاعا متفاوت الحده في اسعار المواد
الغذائيه والوقود نفس التحديات تواجه
مناطق اخرى في القاره كالسودان الذي يواجه
كذلك ويلات الحرب
فالى اي مدى يفسر هذا الوضع سعيا الافارقه
الى القيام بدوري الوساطه في الازمه
الاوكرانيه وما هي حظوظ النجاح في تلك
الوساطه
نتمنى الصادقين ان تعطى الوساطه الافريقيه
فرصتها لكي نتمكن في نهايه المطاف من
انهاء هذه الاسئله
كان ذلك سفير مالي لدى الولايات المتحده
سيكوبرتي في مقابله خاصه مع برنامج من
واشنطن في مقر الاقامه الروسيه في العاصمه
الامريكيه وسنعرض المقابله كامله بعد قليل
وقد رحبت اداره الرئيس بايدن بالوساطه
الافريقيه
سندعم اي عرض للسلام يقدمه اي طرف طالما
تمتع بالمصداقيه والقابليه للتطبيق
والاستمراريه ومع توفر هذه العناصر
الثلاثه ينبغي ان يكون العرض مدعوما من
قبل الرئيس زيلينسكي والشعب الاوكراني
رؤساء الست دول افريقيه ستقوم بدور
الوساطه وهي اوغندا وزامبيا ومصر والكونغو
والسنغال وجنوب افريقيا قبل ان نخوض في
ملف الوساطه الافريقيه والعلاقات الروسيه
الافريقيه في ظل تنافس القوى الدوليه
الكبرى في القاره نعود لموضوع الاثار
الاقتصاديه لحرب اوكرانيا على مختلف الدول
الافريقيه كان نقص في امدادات الحبوب
وارتفاع اسعار المواد الغذائيه والوقود
وقد جاءت هذه الازمه واثارها في اعقاب
الاضرار الاقتصاديه البالغه التي خلفتها
جائحه كورونا ارحب الان بيئه هنا اذيه
كونوا مساعده الامين العام للامم المتحده
ومديره مكتب افريقيا الاقليمي لبرنامج
الامم المتحده الانماء تنضم الي مشكوره من
مكتب الجزيره في نيويورك
السيده
بالنسبه
لمشكله النقص في الحبوب في القمح تحديدا
لنبدا بذلك اين تقع مشكله النقص في
امدادات الحبوب
افريقيا على سلم التحديات او الاثار
الاقتصاديه لحرب اوكرانيا في افريقيا
شكرا جزيلا يسعدني ان اكون معكم في هذا
البرنامج
تاثيرات هذه الحرب الاوكرانيه على
اقتصادات
الافريقيه شديده جدا القمح هو مجرد بعد
واحد من هذه التاثيرات فكما نعلم العديد
من الدول في القاره الافريقيه تستورد
كميات كبيره من قمحها من اوكرانيا وروسيا
بعض الدول تعتمد مئه بالمئه على على
استيرادها من القمح من هذين البلدين دول
مثل سودان ومصر لديهما اعلى نسبه اعتماد
عليهم وبالتالي ففورا فوق تاثيرات الفوريه
كانت الزياده في ارتفاع الاسعار كل السلع
الغذائيه وايضا الوقود لان الشيء الاخر
يتاثر ايضا هو كان الاسمده واعتقد ان
الصدمه كانت مدى سرعه تاثير ذلك على
المنازل بعد بدء الحرب في شهر فبراير شباط
وان هذا التاثير
عصابه في الوقت ذاته الدول التي كما تزال
في حاله نقاهه او استشفاء من اثار جائحه
كوفي 19
وكما ان هناك تاثيرات اخرى كثيره من
التغيرات المناخيه وطبعا
[موسيقى]
النزاعات التي تشهدها بعض الدول وبالتالي
هناك تاثيرات كبيره جدا على الكثير من هذه
الازمات من هذه الازمات وايضا تاثيرات
زياده اسعار الغذاء ايضا يؤثر على نسب
التضخم للسلع الاخرى اعطيكم مثال فشهر
الذره التي
التي التضخم فيها وصله 80 بالمئه فلو كنت
تشتري علبه ذره بعشره دولار في يوم ما وفي
اليوم الثاني ستشتوي بثمانين دولار فبدون
زياده مدخولاتك وبالتالي هذا فعلا يعتبر
وصفه
لفقدان الامن الغذائي تشدوا كثير من الدول
العالم
باختصار يعني مساله النقص في امدادات
الحبوب تحديدا القمح يعني هل او ما حده
التفاوت في هذه المشكله بين منطقه في
افريقيا ومنطقه اخرى شمال افريقيا جنوب
افريقيا شرق افريقيا الوسط ما حده التفاوت
انه فعلا هذا يعتبر قضيه وجوديه من حيث
الاساس فاذا كنت معتمدا لنقل على سبيل
المثال كان
اعتمادك الرئيسي هو على الغذاء كغد كطعام
وهذا ما ينطبق على الدول مثل السودان
وفجرت لن تجد نفسك غير قادر على الوصول
الى سكانك او ايصال هذا الخبز الى سكانك
بسعر معقول فهذه الزياده في الاسعار تزيد
خطر اضطرابات الاجتماعيه وشاهدنا ذلك فعلا
يحصل في بعض اجزاء القاره ولكن ما اعتقد
انه هو اكثر اهميه هو ما ادت اليه هذه
التاثيرات والضغوط في بعض الدول فيما
يتعلق قيام بجولات
حديث جديد حول الاعتماد على الذات
وقطاع سلسله الامدادات التي كنتم تجده
اسمده في الق ايضا تنتج القمع في البلاد
فسيكون ذلك
ان يصلوا
للتقريب هذه
السلعه الى المنازل وبالتالي فان هناك هذه
الاسئله حول وجود هذه المواد حول التصنيع
وايضا التوافقات الاقليميه في تشجيع منطقه
التجاره الحره في افريقيا والسوق الحر
والفسوق المشتركه الافريقيه او بحيث
الاخيره يمكن
هناك تغيير في هيكل الاقتصاد بدل مجرد
الاعتماد على استيراد المواد الاوليه
بالقيمه مضافه وايضا التاكد بان هناك
انتاجيه في القاره
وتقليل الاعتماديه اذا كانت تاثيرات سيئه
وقاسيه سواء في مصر او في جنوب افريقيا
مساعده الامين العام يعني انت ذكرت
السودان ذكرتي مصر طبعا لا يمكن الحديث عن
السودان دون ومصر دون الحديث عن نهر النيل
وبالتالي يعني القاره الافريقيه غنيه
بالامطار في العديد من مناطقها غنيه
بالانهار غنيه بالغابات غنيه بالاراضي
الزراعيه في العديد من مناطقها ومع ذلك
نسمع عن هذا النقص في
الحبوب
كالقمح مثلا يعني كيف يفسر هذا الوضع
ليس من السهل تفسيره وشرح ذلك كما قلت انت
هذه قاره غنيه
بالمنى التحتيه الزراعيه
لدينا كان ستين بالمئه
من الاراضي الصالحه للزراعه والغير
المستفاد منها وبالتالي الامريت على قله
موارد ولكن بعض هذه خصمه جدا ولكن ما
يعوزنا
والتكنولوجيا والرؤس المال
وموارد الماليه والى حد ما القدرات
القدرات لتحويل هذه الاراضي الى الى عب
شيئا مفيد في القطاع الزراعي ولكن اضافه
الى انه ان هناك بنيه تحتيه بمعالجه
المواد الغذائيه وليس مجرد استيرادها
وبحالتها الخام
ولانه انا ذاك يمكن ان نكسب نستفيد اكثر
من هذه المنتجات اللي بحيث نستطيع ان نزيد
معدلات الاقتصاد والطبقه الوسطى اذا قارن
افريقيا تتوفر كل الظروف المناسبه لتغذي
نفسها بنفسها ولكن ذلك يتطلب دعما كبيرا
في مجالات التكنولوجيا ونقل التكنولوجيا
في مجال بناء القدرات وايضا في بنجال
تقديم الموارد الماليه والقدرات اللازمه
للتحقيق ذلك لان هناك صدمات في الواقع
تؤخر امكانيه
استفاد من هذه الموارد الاراضي مثلا
التغيرات هي كما ذكرت سابقا هذه الصدمات
تؤدي الى خلق التوتر وكثير وتؤدي الى
امكانيه عدم استفاده من الموارد اذا لكن
هذه العقبات
ليس في امرا لا يمكن تجاوزه لكن الامر
يتطلب تضامن تضامن بحيث يمكن
ودعم الدول الافريقيه لتسطيع ان تستفيد من
موارزها التي لديها للكثير من هذه الصدمات
الواقع مصدرها خارجي
وعطفا عليه اذا امكننا ان اسال سؤال اخير
السيده كونوا بالنسبه للعامل الخارجي كما
تفضلت الان يعني ما مدى الدعم الذي تلقاه
القاره سواء من الجانب الروسي ونحن نتحدث
عن الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه او من الجانب
الغربي الولايات المتحده فرنسا بريطانيا
تحديدا في المجال الغذائي مثلا
الامين العام للامم المتحده لطالما ادعى
الى
اولا اتخاذ اجراءات التاكد من ان المنتجات
تجداس الموانع عن طريق البحر الاسود مثلا
هو خاصه بعض
بعض الاحتياجات الطارئه العاجله القائمه
حاليا فهناك فعلا نزاعات
ادت الى نزوح عادات كبيره من السكان في
القرن الافريقي مؤخرا كان لدينا جفاف كبير
في منطقه ظهر القرن الافريقي ادت الى
فقدان الامن الغذائي بشكل كبير وكان
استيراد المواد الغذائيه لدعم السكان اللي
كان يواجهون مثل هذه الازمات وكان ذلك هو
موضوع الحديث الذي قام به الامين العام
لمتحده مع زعماء المنطقه والعالم وذلك
للتاكد نستطيع غلق هذه الفجوه فيما يتعلق
بمعاناه الشعوب الذين هم ضعفاء جدا لانه
اما قد كانوا كانوا امهم نازحين بسبب
الحرب او النزاعات او فقط لانهم يعيشون
تحت الظروف لا يمكن لهم ان يعتمدوا على ما
يتوفر لديهم حاليا وهذا هذا الامر يبقى
امراك احتياجات كبيره لابد من ان نلبيها
فيما يتعلق على المستوى الطارئ والعاجل
ولكن في الوقت ذاته هناك اهميه للنظر فيه
البنيه العالميه للتمويلات الماليه
هذه الانظمه
تبعث ما يكفي من اموال لساعد الدول على
مواجهه هذه الضربات الكبيره اما النتيجه
جائحه او تغييرات مناخيه والنزاعات
وبالتالي هذه كلها الدعوه للمزيد من
الانظمه العالميه وايضا للدعوه للتضامن
وذلك
وسد الشد سد بعض هذه الفجوات
مساهمات هامه للصراع ضد الاستعمار والتعصب
والفصل العنصري كما هرعت بلادنا لمساعده
الدول في الحصول على استقلالها والدفاع
عنها الان روسيا تواصل سياساتها في الدعم
الكامل للدول الافريقيه
السفير الروسي لدى الولايات المتحده انا
طولي انتونوف كان يتحدث في وقت سابق هذا
الاسبوع في حفل اقامه في مقر اقامته في
واشنطن وقد اقيم الحفظ الحفل في سياق
الاستعدادات الروسيه لاحتضان القمه
الروسيه الافريقيه الثانيه في مدينه سانت
بيترز الروسيه اواخر شهر يوليو المقبل وقد
حضر الحفل عدد من دبلوماسيين وسفراء الدول
الافريقيه بمن فيها تلك التي عززت
علاقاتها مع موسكو في الاونه الاخيره
كمالي المستعمره الفرنسيه السابقه
انترف اكد على ما وصفه باهتمام روسيا
بعلاقاتها مع افريقيا ليس من باب المنافسه
مع اي دوله اخرى كما قال بل من باب
الاهتمام بتلك العلاقات في حد ذاتها
الاساسيه من وراء القمه الروسيه الافريقيه
واود التاكيد على هذا هي تعزيز سياده
الدول الافريقيه وتقويه دورها في الشؤون
الدوليه الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين منفتح على
الاتصالات المشتركه والمحادثات مع كافه
الشركاء على هامش القمه المرتقبه
دوله مالي نموذج افريقي في منطقه الساحل
المتاخمه للشمال الافريقي نموذج للضربات
التي تهدد العديد من دول القاره التي اما
تربطها علاقات تقليديه مع روسيا كوارث
للاتحاد السوفياتي او قامت بتعزيز
علاقاتها مع موسكو في الاونه الاخيره وقد
شهدت مالي سلسله من الانقلابات العسكريه
في السنوات القليله الماضيه بالتوازي مع
تحديات امنيه كبيره تتمثل فيما تصفه
باماكو وعواصم عديده اخرى
بحرب مكافحه الارهاب على هامش الحفل الذي
اقامه السفير الروسي في اقامته في واشنطن
استعدادا للقمه الروسيه الافريقيه الثانيه
قابلت السفيره المالي لدى الولايات
المتحده سيكوبرتي
[موسيقى]
السيد السفير اسعد الله اوقاتك وشكرا على
هذه المقابله مع برنامج من واشنطن على
قناه الجزيره
تابعت خطاب السفير الروسي ما هو اكثر ما
استوقفك في كلامه بونجور
[موسيقى]
اهلا وشكرا على الدعوه هذا شرف لي روسيا
اليوم شارك كبير لمالي نحن نعيش وضعا صعبا
في مالي بسبب الارهاب مالي بلد فرض عليه
الارهاب منذ سقوط القذافي فهناك من شدوا
حقائبهم وحملوا اسلحتهم ودخلوا الاراضي
الماليه باسم الدين وباسم اجنده معينه نحن
نجهلها
ومنذ ذلك الوقت لم تعرف ماليا السلام اما
اليوم وبفضل التعاون مع روسيا فنحن قادرون
على تسيير امورنا بحيث تراجع الارهاب على
اراضينا وذلك بسبب الجهود التي بذلناها
تحت رعايه فخامه الرئيس اسيمي
[موسيقى]
وبفضل يقظته وجهوده فان الارهاب يتقهقر
اليوم وتتزايد قوه جيشنال
[موسيقى]
وتقرر اجراء الانتخابات الاستفت في مطلع
يونيو في بلادنا
ان هذه فرصه لكي اهنئ على نجاح التعاوننا
مع روسيا في المجال العسكري وفي مجال
الامدادات في العتاد ونحن ممتنون للرئيس
الروسي وللسلطات الروسيه
هذا التحسن في العلاقات بين مالي وروسيا
تسبب في كثير من الاضطرابات في علاقات
مالي مع الغرب بصوره عامه ومع فرنسا
والولايات المتحده بشكل خاص كيف تعالجون
هذا الملف
لقد قلنا اننا منفتحون على جميع الشركاء
كيفما كانوا فليس لدينا اي مشكله مع
الامريكيين اننا منفتحون على الشراكه
الامريكيه وعلى شراكه اخرى وعليه طالما
انك تحترم خياراتنا وطالما انك تحترم رغبه
الشعب المالي فليس لدينا اي مشكله مع اي
جهه وعلى الجهات الغربيه ان تتفهم الوضع
المالي هنا
لقد كنا على شفا ان نختفي من الخريطه
العالميه كبلد ولولا يقظه السلطات الماليه
لكن اليوم بلدا منبودا نشكر الله ونشكر
السلطات الحكومه الانتقاليه التي بذلت كل
الجهود لهانه مالي على الوقوف على رجليها
كذلك بفضل تعاوننا مع الروسماسيون
[موسيقى]
اذا اغتنم هذه الفرصه لتقديم الشكر الى
روسيا وللقول كذلك ان كل الشركات مرحبا
بها في ماليه
السيد السفير كما تعرف الامريكيون مثلا
يقولون ان اقامه علاقات مصانه بشكل جيد مع
الروس شيء ولكن اقامه علاقات مع مجموعه
مثل مجموعه فاغنر شيء اخر ماذا تقول انت
في ذلك
لقد قلت هذا للامريكيين في كل مره اجتمعت
بهم لقد اشترينا عتادا عسكريا من روسيا
وكاي بلد اخر يشتري عددا عسكريا يوفد
مدربون اليه لتكوين عطوره العسكريه
والتدريبه على استخدام ذلك العتاد وفي هذا
السياق لدينا مدربون روس في مالي لكي
يدربوا العسكريين الماليين على استخدام
السلاح الروسي
واذا فهم بعض الشركات ذلك بطريقه مختلفه
واعطوه علامه فان ذلك ليس مشكله نحن
الماضيين لقد قلنا ذلك مرارا وتكرارا ليس
لدينا قوات تابعه لفاجنر بل لدينا مدربون
روس في اطار تعاوننا مع روسيا وهو تعاون
بين الدولتين هذا ما قلته لكل من تحدثت
اليهم من الجانب الامريكي
[موسيقى]
لدوله مالي ولكن بصفتك دبلوماسي افريقي
بشكل عام كذلك هناك العديد من الافارقه
الذين يشتكون من الاثار الاقتصاديه للحرب
في اوكرانيا على افريقيا كيف تنظر الى هذا
الملف الاثار الاقتصاديه على افريقيا
للغزو الروسي لاوكرانيا
اريد ان اقول انه في الحاله الماليه وبسبب
هذه الازمه ليس لدينا اسمده لقطعنا
الزراعي ليس لدينا ما يكفي المزارعين من
تلك المواد هذه احدى الاثار الوخيمه لهذه
الازمه في اوكرانيا نامل في هذه السنه ان
يتم كل ما يمكن لكي نحصل على اكبر كميه
ممكنه من السماد لمواجهه المخاطر الانيه
فاذا كانت هناك ازمه غذا
على اصدقائنا الغربيين ان يقوموا بكل ما
يمكنهم القيام به لكي تحصل افريقيا بصوره
عامه ومالي بصوره خاصه على ما يكفيها من
الاسمده لاعطاء المزارعين فرصه لانتاج
محاصيل زراعيه بصوره مريحه وهذه صيحه من
القلب اليهم الحصول على الاسمده هذا احد
المشاغل الكبيره لدينا
موجودين
[موسيقى]
هناك حاليا جاهز افريقي للوساطه بين
اوكرانيا وروسيا هل تشعر ان لهذه الوساطه
حظوظ حقيقيه للنجاح
نزفرون اتمنى ذلك اتمنى ان تنجح هذه
الوساطه الافريقيه وهو شرف لافريقيا
والدبلوماسيه الافريقيه ولكلنا فارقه
نتمنى الصادقين ان تعطى الوساطه الافريقيه
فرصتها لكي نتمكن في نهايه المطاف من
انهاء هذه الاسئله
كان ذلك السفير المالي لدى الولايات
المتحده سيكوبرتي كنت قد قابلت في وقت
سابق كذلك جوزيف ثاني نائب رئيس مركزي
افريقيا بمعهد الولايات المتحده للسلام
دكتور جوزيف ثاني مرحبا بك في برنامج من
واشنطن على قناتي الجزيره في البدايه هذا
الصراع بين روسيا
واوكرانيا
والمحاولات الافريقيه كما نسمع الان
للتوسط
لايجاد تسويه لهذا النزاع الى اي مدى يحرك
الوضع الغذائي لافريقيا
هذه الرغبه في الوساطه من قبل الافارقه
اعتقد اولا وقبل كل شيء شكرا لك على
استضافتي هذا النقاش ياتي في الوقت
المناسب تماما لانه كما تعلم قبل الحرب
كانت القاره الافريقيه تكافح بالفعل مع
تبعات كوفي 19 لذا عندما اندلعت الحرب بين
روسيا واوكرانيا كان تاثيرها كبيرا وكانت
هذه البلدان الافريقيه تواجه عدم استقرار
اقتصادي وصعوبات في احتياجات السكان بسبب
الوباء وانهيار سبل العيش بالطبع لذلك
عندما اندلع الصراع شهيدنا ارتفاعا في
اسعار الاسمده والغذاء والوقود وهذه امور
حاسمه لاقتصاد تلك البلدان وخاصه بالنسبه
للاسري هناك فالذين تضرروا بشده كانوا
الاكثر فقرا وبالتالي خلقت الحرب نوعا من
حال الاستعجال والطوارئ للبلدان الافريقيه
وايضا من الطبيعي ان يحاول القاره
الافارقه ايجاد طرق لوضع حد للصراع واعتقد
ان هذا امر طبيعي لان المساله تتعلق بقدره
هذه الشعوب على البقاء والاستمرار
بالنسبه للعديد من الدول الافريقيه
وهذا الوضع الغذائي يعني لديهم مصلحه
غذائيه في علاقه جيده مع اوكرانيا
ولديهم مصلحه في علاقات جيده مع روسيا
كذلك من حيث
بعض المواد التي تستخدم في مختلف قطاعات
الاقتصاد في افريقيا انما هل المحرك
الرئيسي لهذه الوساطه بتصور هو العامل
الغذائي ام الولاءات والتحالفات القديمه
التي ورثها ورثتها روسيا عن الاتحاد
السوفيتي في افريقيا
الامر اكثر تعقيدا من ذلك اولا وقبل كل
شيء اعتقد انها افريقيا لديها الكثير
لتخسره جراء صراع مثل هذا لا يوجد ما هو
مفيد نتيجه الصراع مطول بين روسيا
واوكرانيا هذا هو الامر الاول
كانت التوقعات تشير الى ان الناتج المحلي
الاجماليه الافريقي سيصل بدون وقوع الحرب
الى ثمانيه فاصله واحد في المئه في عام
وانتهى الامر الى ان وصل الى اربعه فاصل
واحد في المئه فقط هذا بسبب تاثير تلك
الحرب على الاقتصادات الافريقيه ولكن
بالاضافه الى ذلك تتسبب الحرب في اعاده
ترتيب للنظام العالمي وهذا يزلزل اليات
السلام والامن القائمه والتي تعتمد عليها
الدول الافريقيه لتحقيق السلام والامن في
بلدانها لذا فالامر بالنسبه لافريقيا لا
يتعلق بالولاء لروسيا او لاوكرانيا بل
يتعلق بالاستقرار والسلام لديهم لانهم
يريدون التنميه ويعرفون انه دون سلام لن
توجد تنميه ولن يوجد امن لذلك من المصلحه
الوطنيه ان يتحقق السلام في اوكرانيا
اريد ان نعود لاحقا الى الجانب الامني في
بلدان كمالي مثلا انما قبل ذلك يعني
بالنسبه للجانب الاقتصادي يعني اين تكمن
المصلحه الاكبر بالنسبه للدول الافريقيه
هل تكمن في علاقاتها مع روسيا ام تكمن في
علاقاتها مع الغرب سواء كان ذلك فرنسا
بريطانيا او الولايات المتحده
هذا سؤال مثير للاهتمام للغايه اولا لا
يمكن لروسيا على مستوى الاقتصادي لا يمكنه
التعامل مع متطلبات التنميه الافريقيه
فليست لنا روسيا القدره على ذلك عندما
تنظر الى روسيا تجد انها الى حد بعيد تمثل
شريكا عسكريا او بائع اسلحه لافريقيا هذا
امر مؤكد ولكن افريقيا لا تحتاج الى
السلاح لتط نفسها اولويات البلدان
الافريقيه هي التعليم والخدمات الاساسيه
والنمو الاقتصادي والتجاره والاستثمار
وروسيا ليس لديها القدره على تحقيق تلك
الاهداف في الوقت نفسه الشركاء التقليديون
للبلدان الافريقيه اي الولايات المتحده
والاتحاد الاوروبي والصين يمتلكون هذه
القدرات
لذا اذا كانت المبادره الافريقيه من اجل
السلام لها دوافع اقتصاديه فستكون
الخيارات اسهل وستعمل الدول الافريقيه مع
الغرب وليس مع روسيا ولكن مره اخرى لا
يمكن استبعاد الروابط التاريخيه بين روسيا
وبعض الدول الافريقيه وفي نهايه المطاف
الدول الافريقيه ناضجه بما يكفي لتعرف اين
تكمن مصلحتها
واعتقد انها مع اولئك الذين يمكنهم ان
يوفروا التنميه والاستثمار المالي واعتقد
ان هذا هو الغرب
يعني في حالات بعض الدول مثلا دول الساحل
لناخذ على سبيل المثال مالي مالي تقليديا
كانت مستعمره فرنسيه بعد الاستقلال وصفت
نفسها بانها حليف للفرنسيين في تلك
المنطقه الان في الاونه الاخيره طبعا مالي
اقتربت او تقاربت اكثر في علاقتها مع
روسيا يعني هذا التحول في التحالفات لبعض
هذه الدول الافريقيه يعني الى اي مدى يخدم
المصلحه الامنيه لهذه الدوله علما بان بعض
الدول في الوقت الراهن تعتبر ان المصلحه
الامنيه تاتي اولا واخيرا
[موسيقى]
مره اخرى اقول سؤالك ملائم تماما قلت قبل
هذا ان الدول الافريقيه تتبع مصلحتها
الوطنيه في الوقت الحالي الاولويه لدى بعض
الدول هي تحقيق الامن وبالاخص الامن من
منظور عسكري لذلك بالنسبه لهذه الدول
روسيا لا توفر الحل لديك مثلا الحاله في
دوله مالي او جمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى على
سبيل المثال حيث قامت روسيا بدمج بعض
الجماعات شبه العسكريه ولاسيما فاجنر في
تلك الدول بطريقه مثيره للقلق للغايه لانه
كما نعلم في حاله مالي المشكله في مالي
انه على الرغم من ان الاعراض هي انعدام
الامن الا ان الاسباب الجذريه لتلك
المشاكل ليست انعدام الامن في مالي بل ان
الحكام والتنميه يحتاجان الى النمو
الاقتصادي
وبالطبع الطريقه التي اتبعتها السلطات في
مالي وبعض الدول الاخرى لتاطير اولوياتها
من الناحيه الامنيه هي وضعها في الاطار
العسكري وهذا امر مؤسف لان السبب الجذري
للمشكله ليس عسكريا بل هو مشكله الحكم
والتنميه الاقتصاديه والنمو
كان ذلك الدكتور جوزيف ساني نائب رئيس
مركز افريقيا بمعهد الولايات المتحده
للسلام قابلته في وقت سابق هذا الاسبوع
ارحب الان بكل من
صحفي فرنسي مقيم في الولايات المتحده
ومختص في شؤون الامن الغذائي والشان
الافريقي ومحمد المنشاوي الصحفي المختص في
الشان الامريكي ابدا بك محمد المنشاوي
امكن كانت هناك قمه امريكيه افريقيه نهايه
العام الماضي ماذا تعتقد ان اداره الرئيس
بايدن قد حققته في افريقيا منذ تلك القمه
طبعا هذا حدث في شهر ديسمبر الماضي و16
فقط مرت على هذه القمه ومن المبكر جدا
الحكم عليها لكن هي خرجت بتوصيات مبشره
بتعاون ووضع اساس جديد لعلاقات امريكيه
افريقيه
مستقبليه بعد الرده التي حدثت وتذبذب الذي
شهدته علاقات
الولايات المتحده مع القاره الافريقيه
خلال الحكم الرئيس بايدن عندما انتخب
الرئيس ترامب عفوا عندما تخبر رئيس السابق
باراك اوباما افترض افريقيا انها ستبدا
فاصلا جديدا مع الولايات المتحده هناك
رئيس اسود في البيت الابيض هناك اكثر من
40 مليون امريكي وسلوم افريقيه وافترض ان
الولايات المتحده تعتني كثيرا بالكره
الافريقيه لكن الاعتماد والتركيز الامريكي
انصب على الجانب الامني
والمكافحه الارهاب فقط اليوم هناك نفوس
كبير للصين هناك نفوز متصاعد مزعج جدا
لروسيا في القاره الافريقيه واداره بايدن
تنبهت لهذه المخاطر وعقدت هذه القمه
لاصلاح العلاقات الامريكيه الافريقيه
ومحاوله موجبها النفوس ام الصاعد لروسيا
والصين في القاره
يعني هناك متاعب اقتصاديه ناتجه عن
في اوكرانيا على افريقيا كما سبقت الاشاره
ولكن هل يمكن القول بان هناك كذلك منافع
من حيث انه افريقيا اصبحت محل تنافس اكبر
مما كان عليه الوضع في السابق بين الصين
وروسيا من جهه وبين الغرب ممثل في
الولايات المتحده وفرنسا
ربما بريطانيا كذلك من جهه اخرى هل هذه
منفعه ناتجه عن الحرب في اوكرانيا
لافريقيا
علينا ان نرجع خطوه الى الوراء فالعلاقه
بين افريقيا
وروسيا تعود الى
لحظات بعد استقلال الدول الافريقيه في ذلك
الوقت للكثير الدول الافريقيه الرغبه
بالتخلص
وتخليص انفسهم من المستعمرين خاصه فرنسيين
وكانوا يطلعون شرقا في سياق الستينيات
والسبعينيات
اتحاد السوفيتي انا ذاك التعامل بين دوله
افريقيه والاتحاد السوفيتي اصبح قويا جدا
في كثير من جوانب ذلك التعليم وغيره وهذا
طبعا استمر لجيل من الموظفين الحكوميين
الذين تدربوا وحصل على التعليم جيد في
روسيا طبعا عند انهيار الاتحاد السوفيتي
هذا التعاون تهوى وتراجع
بدا يعود الى قوته اذا ان روسيا تعود الى
لتصبح قوه دوليه في العالم هو الدول
الافريقيه تعرف بان هذه علاقه باتجاهين
فروسيا تحتاج افريقيا وهذا خاصه صحيح في
سياق الحرب مع اوكرانيا
في الشؤون الدوليه وان روسيا لديها بذلك
فرص
لان تكون المجهز العسكري الدول الافريقيه
وبالتالي فهذا امر جديد لكن هو في الواقع
عوده الى علاقات كانت تعاون كبير فيها بين
افريقيا في افريقيا والاتحاد السوفيتي
واليوم افريقيا وروسيا
محمد المنشاوي يعني عطفا عليه بالنسبه
لاداره الرئيس باين وساطه افريقيه نابعه
من هذا السياق التاريخي
البيت الابيض قال انه يدعم هذه الوساطه
وبالتالي اسالك يعني عندما تكون هذه
الوساطه تتزعمها دوله جنوب افريقيا لها
علاقات تقليديه قويه مع الروس ومصر لها
علاقات مع الغرب ولكن في الاونه الاخيره
نحت في بشكل ما نحو روسيا ماذا يعني الدعم
الامريكي للوساطه الافريقيه في الازمه
الاوكرانيه بناء عليه اداره الرئيس بايدن
تريد وقف القتال في في اوكرانيا وانهاء
الغزو او ايقاف الغزو الروسي على الاراضي
الاوكرانيه ايا كان الوسيط هنا سواء كانت
الصين رحبت بذلك او كانت الدول الافريقيه
الدول الافريقيه تحاول ان تقف في منطقه
الحياد بين اوكرانيا وبين روسيا
وهي لا تملك الكثير من الاوراق والكروت
الضاغطه على اي طرف سواء كان اوكرانيا او
روسيا
لدفعهم لوقف القتال لكن هي تحاول ان تبرز
ان القار الافريقيه اصبح لها اهميه
متزايده في عالم اليوم عالم في صراع قوى
كبرى في كل مناطق العالم وافريقيا على راس
هذه المناطق لما بها من موارد معدنيه ضخمه
جدا وموارد سكانيه هناك اكثر من مليار
نسمه الان في القاره الافريقيه فالدعم
الامريكي للوصاه الافريقيه هو دعم مرحب به
هنا في واشنطن وتريد اداره بدن وقف القتال
وربما منح الافارقه فرصه للضغط على روسيا
اذا كانت تملك اي اوراق في هذا الطريق
يعني ايه الاداره الامريكيه تقول ترحب
بالوساطه الافريقيه شريطه ان يقبل بها ليس
الروس فقط بل يقبل بها الاوكرانيون كذلك
يعني كلا الطرفين الروسي والاوكراني قال
انه يقبل بالوساطه الافريقيه
عطفا علي اسالك مره اخرى يعني ما مدى
القيمه التي تضعها الولايات المتحده على
الوساطه الافريقيه علما بان العديد من
الدول التي تشارك الافريقيه التي تشارك في
هذه الوساطه ليس لها ربما نفس القدر من
التقدير لعلاقتها مع واشنطن كما تقدر
علاقتها مع موسكو رسميا تدعم الوساطه
الافريقيه لكن في الطرقات واذا تحدثت لاي
مسؤول امريكي سيؤكد لك ان لا حظوظ او
لنجاح مثل هذه الوساطه الافارقه ليس لديهم
اي قروض للضغط على روسيا لسحب قواتها او
وقف القتال على عكس الصين الصين هي التي
تملك ربما وسائل للضغط على على روسيا في
هذا المجال الدول الافريقيه التي تحاول
اغضاب روسيا هي تعتمد عليها في في الغذاء
بصوره كبيره وتحاول ارضاء الغرب
الجديد الولايات المتحده القائده وليس لها
ارث استعماري كفرنسا او بريطانيا او
بلجيكا وهي حره لها حريه في التحرك في
افريقيا على عكس الدوله الفرنسيه فاعتقد
ان واشنطن تدرك ان الحظوظ الافارقه في فرد
هدنه في اوكرانيا في اوكرانيا ضعيفه جدا
لكنها تشجعها على اي حال
ماذا عنك انت يعني بالنسبه للعديد من
الدول ذكرنا ماليكا مثال منطقه الساحل
كمثال اوسع يعني كيف تعتقد ان هذه الدول
في افريقيا توفق بين حاجتها الامنيه للروس
في الحاله الماليه مثلا
وحاجاتها للغرب في قضايا اقتصاديه
لقد سمعنا من السفير سفيره مالي
بانه هناك جانب امن غذائي مهم جدا فيما
يتعلق احتياجات افريقيا اليوم وان الحرب
بالتاكيد اثرت بشكل كبير كما شاهدنا في
كثير الدول اثرت على قدرات هذه الدول
لتوفير الطعام للسكانها ولكن الاجانب ذلك
فان جانب العسكريه والعلاقه مع فرنسا
بالتاكيد تغيرت مؤخرا
فبعد 60 سنه من من التعاون مع فرنسا مالي
بوركينا فاسو وغيرها في غرب افريقيا
العلاقه لم تحقق تقدما كبيرا في مجال
التنميه وان دول مثل موريتانيا واوغندا
الذين لم يكنوا بشكل كبير تحت السيطره
فرنسا ولم
وهم وامرهم تكون جيده ولم تحسان وبالتالي
فانها الان هناك تمرضات او الثورات حصلت
مالي وغيرها
واول نتائج ذلك كان في الجوانب العسكريه
حيث ان التعاون مع روسيا قدم
بعض
بعضا امنيا لمالي مثلا حيث انه الفرنسيون
حل محلهم الجيش المالي الذي درب بافضل وجه
اذا افضل من قبل روسيا وايضا ثم ايضا
مجموعه
عوده للسلام وضع السالم اكثر في مالي وهذه
العلاقه فعلا بدات تاتي اكلها بالنسبه
لمالي واليوم في بوركينا فاسيو نشاهد
سيناريو مشابه فحيث ان الشعب
ضاقوا ذرعا بعدم وجود التنميه
تدعيه المساعدات التنمويه الفرنسيه
وبالتالي
لنحصل على الحلول من روسيا
محمد منشاوي مساله طبعا الولايات المتحده
تتهم دول كمالي تقول انه دول اخرى عكس
السودان توجد فيها قوات لمجموعه فاجنر
الروسيه في الحاله السودانيه مثلا يعني
اين ترى انت
المحاوله السودانيه للتوفيق بينما تحتاجه
السودان من روسيا في الجانب الامني روسيا
سواء الدوله او مجموعه وما تحتاجه من
الغرب خاصه في وضع الحرب الحالي في البلاد
الوضع السوداني شديد التعقيد حكومه الرئيس
السابقه البشير تعهدت لروسيا بمنحها قاعده
عسكريه في بجوار ميناء بورسودان في البحر
الاحمر ووسط انتفضت ضد هذه الاتفاقيه
واعتقد انها عطلتها ونجحت في تعطيلها حتى
الان كما ذكرت روسيا
توفر بعض السلاح لبعض الفصائل السودانيه
الان لكن
ما تملكه الولايات المتحده اكثر من السلاح
تملك الكثير ام شيء في هذه المرحله في
صراع السودانيه الشرعيه الدوليه واوشط هي
المفاوضه الاكبر والطرف الاكبر في الصراع
السوداني من حيث الوساطه الى جانب المملكه
السعوديه ووسط هي ايضا بوابه الاعتراف
الدولي بالطرف المنتصر في هذه الحرب اذا
انتهت الى انتصار طرف واحد فبدون واشط لا
يستطيع السودان التحرك للامام سواء دوليا
او ماليا او اقتصاديا ربما يوفر الروس بعض
الاسلحه هنا وهناك لكن السودان لا تحتاج
الاسلحه في هذه الفتره هي تحتاج اكثر من
ذلك وهذا بيد واشنطن وليس بيد موسكو
فلافيوس بتصورك يعني اين تلتقي المصلحه
الامريكيه مع مصلحه الاتحاد الاوروبي مثلا
في الحاله السودانيه او في حاله بعض الدول
في الساحل الافريقي
[موسيقى]
انهم يتوافقان بمعنى ان كل من الاتحاد
الاوروبي
وخاصه فرنسا والولايات المتحده
لا يتطلعون لحد كبير ليكونوا في حاله
تنافس مع روسيا كما كان الحال ايام الحرب
البارده قد تكون هناك مقاومه ضد اي شيء
تقوم به روسيا مع افريقيا ولكن وكما قلنا
السياق
وارث روسيا ووجودها روسيا عبر الاتحاد
السوفيتي وبالتالي
ادى ذلك الى نجاح العلاقات وان الدول
الافريقيه
الماده ترى ان لديها فائده تحققها بالعوده
الى
خلق التنافس ما بين القطبين ولكن عندما
اسمع
من اصدقائه الى فارقه ارى ان هناك فهم
لديهم بان افريقيا يجب ان تعرف ما هي
مصالحها الخاصه ما هي
مصلحتها في تجديد العلاقات مع روسيا هناك
وعي لديهم بان مصلحه الاساسيه لروسيا في
افريقيا ليست التنميه البعض قال لي بانه
منذ عقود لم يشاهدوا وزير خارجيه روسيا في
افريقيا
وبالتالي الدول الافريقيه في الواقع
هذه العوده القويه للتعاون والشراكه مع
روسيا قد يكون شيئا ايجابيا ولكن لابد
هناك ضروره ما هي المصالحهم وما هي جدتهم
ودفعها
عند التعاون مع روسيا
بالنسبه لمساله الامن الغذائي
والاثار الاقتصاديه للحرب في اوكرانيا على
افريقيا يعني اوروبا والاتحاد الاوروبي
معروف في العديد من مبادراته اتجاه مناطق
مختلفه من العالم يقدم الدعم المالي يقدم
الدعم الغذائي انما اين تلتقي السياسه
الغذائيه للاتحاد الاوروبي مع السياسه
الامريكيه مع السياسه الغذائيه للولايات
المتحده في تخفيف هذا العبء على افريقيا
الناتج عن الحرب في اوكرانيا بتصورك
وكما قال السفير السفير من مالي الى
امريكا هناك بالتاكيد
خطر متزايد في مجال الامن الغذائي بسبب
قله وشحه الحبوب والاسمده ايضا درجه اولى
ليس فقط في مواد غذائيه بل ايضا عن السلع
الاخرى ففي مالي حتى مؤخرا حتى موعد الحرب
كانت واحد ثلاثه اكبر منتجين للخطا في
افريقيا ولكن ارقامها خفضت الى بشكل كبير
لانها لم تحصل على الاسمده وبالتالي
وبالتالي فهناك تشاؤم كبير وشك في
بالاتحاد الاوروبي موقف الاتحاد الاوروبي
ولايه المتحده لتعزيز وتقويه
اتفاقيه الاسمده
والحبوب مع روسيا انا اتصالاتي قالوا لي
بان الدول العبور
يحصلون على حصه اكبر من الاسمده والحبوب
الموجهه الى افريقيا وفي حاله القطن اذا
ما وصلت الاسمده اخيرا فلا تصل في وقت
متاخر وبالتالي
فالادله المهمه والتطبيق الفعلي في الدول
الغربيه لديها اتفاقات لكن في الواقع انها
الدعمها لم يؤدي الى اي نتائج جيده
لافريقيا
شكرا جزيلا
الصحفي الفرنسي مقيم في الولايات المتحده
متخصص في شؤون العقوبات الدوليه وشان
الافريقي شكرا كذلك لمحمد المنشاوي الصحفي
المختص في الشان الامريكي انتهت الحلقه
يمكنكم التواصل معنا كالمعتاد عبر بريدنا
الالكتروني وفيسبوك وتويتر شكرا لكل من
شارك معنا في هذه الحلقه بطبيعه الحال
وشكرا لكم انتم ايضا على المتابعه اينما
كنتم الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]